foreign
I was a junior in undergrad and there
was a senior who was talking about other
deferred enrollment programs and for me
I knew that if I was to get an MBA I
would only want to do that at GSB and
that was the only place I I saw myself
and so I went back into the car and
Googled does Stanford have a deferred
enrollment program saw a little
paragraph on the website and just
applied
and I remember telling my parents and
family who don't come from a business
background what I was doing and they
were just so confused about the program
and what I was applying to but I'm so so
thankful that I did that quick easy
Google search to see if GSB had it and
and the experience that it's it's
provided me
thank you
there are a few reasons that really
motivated me to apply for the Deferred
enrollment program first I I loved
college and being in an academic setting
being in the classroom being around
fascinating professors living on a
campus and the Deferred enrollment
program really allowed me to build that
in into the next chapter of my life
second I I had a feeling that I would
want to take some risks early in my
career and I also knew how hard and
difficult that would be to wrap my head
around
but having a place waiting for me at GSB
would make it a little easier
and then third it was a bit of a why not
I
if I didn't get in I would just apply
again in a couple years from now so it
really seemed like there was no downside
and it was a no-brainer
I really use the deferral period to
explore my interests and passions and
take risks I started as a consultant
with McKinsey in their Chicago office I
served just retail and consumer clients
but functionally did work across the
entire business so did revenue and
Growth work as well as cost work I then
took some time off from McKinsey moved
to New York City and did a full-time
software engineering boot camp I always
regretted not studying computer science
in college and really wanted for fun to
learn how to code and so was able to use
that four months to really go deep and
to learn a new skill
and then most recently before coming to
GSB I started a women's apparel brand
with my co-founder Olivia and
quitting your job leaping into
entrepreneurship is for sure scary but
having knowing I had a spot at GSB
waiting for me made it a little less
scary
coming to GSB has really been incredible
the sandbox of resources that are on
campus is incredible from the classmates
to professors to courses it really
forces us to think about things
differently and then also geographically
grew up on the East Coast spent eight
years in the Midwest and have always
wanted to live on the west coast and
this weather really beats Chicago
Winters thank you
so the great thing about GSB is that
we're all really using these two years
to explore what we want to do next I
know I want to stay in the retail
consumer space and I would love to
continue to build Pareto full time with
my co-founder after graduation
[Music]
two pieces of advice one for an
applicant and one for a student that's
admitted for the applicant
apply just do it there's really no
reason to not throw your hat in the ring
for a for the app for the student that
that's accepted my biggest piece of
advice would be to take advantage of the
Deferred period you're given this
amazing setup and opportunity and
there's no better time to explore your
passions grow as a person and it'll just
make you a put you in a better spot to
utilize your MBA and and to gain so much
more from it
[Music]